Générique
- Kathia Gilder:
Bonjour et bienvenue
dans "Parlement hebdo".
On vous fait revivre
les temps forts
de la semaine
à l'Assemblée nationale
et au Sénat.
- Quentin Calmet:
Bonjour, Bernard Jomier.
Vous êtes sénateur rattaché
au groupe socialiste.
Vous êtes médecin de profession.
- Kathia Gilder:
Le Parlement va-t-il toucher
à l'installation des médecins?
C'est l'enjeu d'une
proposition de loi
pour lutter
contre les déserts médicaux.
Le texte vise
à réformer l'accès
aux soins.
Cette semaine,
députés et sénateurs
ont débattu de la situation
au Proche-Orient.
Elisabeth Borne
a de nouveau condamné
les attaques
barbares du Hamas,
tout en appelant
à une trêve humanitaire.
Quelle politique de l'immigration?
Le projet de loi
tant attendu sera débattu
au Sénat.
La droite refuse
de donner son feu vert
à la régularisation
dans les métiers
en tension.
- Quentin Calmet:
On commence
avec ce texte
sur l'accès aux soins.
La proposition
de loi a été adoptée
après modification
par les sénateurs mercredi soir.
Face à la levée
de boucliers des médecins,
elle ne prévoit pas de mesures
coercitives
sur l'installation
des praticiens
dans les déserts médicaux.
- Je le redis: hélas.
- Une proposition
de loi adoptée
sans grand enthousiasme.
Le texte
ne serait pas à la hauteur
de ses ambitions.
- Les mesures manquent
de vision globale.
Cela ne règle pas l'enjeu.
- Les populations
sont abandonnées.
Il y a urgence à agir.
- Les sénateurs
ont acté une obligation
des médecins du privé
à faire des gardes.
Dans l'ensemble,
le Sénat a largement épuré
le texte initial.
- Toutes les mesures
ambitieuses
de ce texte ont été rejetées.
- La commission
des Affaires sociales
a supprimé les mesures
qu'elle jugeait coercitives.
Le texte initial prévoyait
le rattachement automatique
des médecins libéraux
à des associations locales
pour mieux organiser
la permanence
des soins.
Le Sénat a supprimé
cette disposition.
Le débat s'est
enflammé
autour de la question
des déserts médicaux.
Une centaine de sénateurs veulent
réguler l'installation
des médecins.
Une mesure portée
par Emmanuel Macron.
Les amendements
ont été rejetés
par crainte d'un découragement
des étudiants.
- Il faut inciter
les jeunes à aller voir
la pratique dans un hôpital
de proximité.
Ce n'est pas en votant
une mesure
qui risque de produire
un effet délétère
sur la jeune
génération
que cela va faire
avancer les choses.
- La proposition
de loi est critiquée
par les associations de médecins.
- Nous n'assurerons pas un juste
accès
aux soins
par des improvisations menées
contre les médecins.
- Face au gouvernement
et à la droite,
la gauche a haussé le ton.
- Nous ne savons
plus quoi dire
à nos concitoyens.
- Lorsque l'exercice
libéral ne répond plus,
la puissance publique
doit reprendre
son rôle et organiser les choses.
- Les sénateurs
ont validé
quelques mesures
symboliques,
comme l'expérimentation
d'une option santé
au lycée.
- Quentin Calmet:
Le Sénat réécrit
et adopte la proposition de loi.
La gauche a voté contre ce texte.
L'idée, c'était
d'avoir un meilleur accès
aux soins.
Pourquoi avoir voté contre?
- Bernard Jomier:
Ce texte n'était
ni fait, ni à faire.
Il rate sa cible.
Il fait suite
aux textes précédents
qui datent d'il y a six mois.
Nous l'avons adopté
en juillet, au Sénat.
Quatre mois plus tard,
on revient
avec un nouveau
texte qui affiche
cette ambition de répondre
aux déserts médicaux.
Mais la seule mesure un peu utile,
significative,
c'est le partage
de la permanence
des soins
entre les hôpitaux publics
et les cliniques privées.
Le reste, ça ne change rien.
- Kathia Gilder:
La question centrale,
c'est celle
des déserts médicaux,
avec ce totem de la liberté
d'installation
des médecins.
Qu'en pensez-vous?
Faut-il
le toucher
ou pas à ce qui est vu
comme un totem?
- Bernard Jomier:
En politique,
on a des totems et des symboles.
Est-ce que c'est efficace?
Vous avez un petit
pourcentage du territoire
qui est doté.
Personne ne propose
de retirer les médecins
qui sont dans ces
territoires
pour les envoyer ailleurs.
Ce qui est proposé,
c'est d'interdire
aux jeunes de s'y installer.
Vous avez 3 à 4%
du territoire
qui est doté,
le reste est sous-doté.
A ce rythme,
dans 30 ans,
on n'aura pas résolu la question.
Il faut être sérieux.
C'est dangereux,
de mettre sur la table
des mesures
dont on sait
qu'elles sont inefficaces,
parce qu'on prend
une posture politique.
Derrière, il n'y
a pas de résultats.
Il y a encore plus de colère
et d'exaspération.
Je comprends la colère
et l'exaspération
des personnes
qui n'arrivent
plus à avoir accès à un médecin.
- Quentin Calmet:
Une centaine de sénateurs
ont tenté de revenir
sur l'installation
des médecins.
Les amendements
ont tous été repoussés.
C'est un signal
de défiance envoyé
aux étudiants
de médecine,
pour ces sénateurs.
Peut-on dire que le lobby
des médecins
a gagné sur le lobby
des élus locaux?
-
Bernard Jomier:
Je ne vois pas du tout
les choses
comme ça.
Parfois, ce sont les mêmes.
La seule question
qui vaille,
c'est l'accès
de notre population
au soin.
Si c'était efficace
d'interdire
aux jeunes d'aller
s'installer à Cannes
ou à Biarritz, je voterais pour.
Mais ce n'est pas le cas.
La difficulté,
c'est que c'est forcément long
et complexe.
Je prends un exemple:
les ophtalmos
et la filière visuelle.
La situation
est en train de s'améliorer
nettement.
Les délais baissent.
Pourquoi?
Il y a quasiment 10
ans, on a commencé
à réorganiser
cette filière et à mettre
en place des responsabilités
supplémentaires
pour les orthoptistes,
à mettre en place
des centres où vous voyez
un orthoptiste
et vous ne voyez
l'ophtalmo
que quelques minutes
si votre problème
est simple.
Ca gagne du temps
pour les ophtalmos.
Les délais sont donc
contraints
de se réguler.
Sur les médecins
généralistes,
car c'est beaucoup ça,
le problème
dans l'accès aux soins
de proximité,
il y a la question
des spécialités,
mais c'est surtout les médecins
généralistes.
Le dispositif
des assistants médicaux,
il en est où?
C'est très lent à mettre en place.
Les infirmières
de pratiques avancées,
en ambulatoire,
que les syndicats
de médecins réclament
pour la plupart:
à peine 200.
On ne finance pas leur formation.
Il faudrait en former 10.000
très rapidement.
Il faudrait leur permettre
de s'installer.
Tous ces dispositifs,
qui visent à partager
les soins, à faire
monter en puissance
des professions
qui ont une démographie
favorable...
Tout ça est beaucoup trop lent.
Il y a trop de volonté.
Il faut un dispositif
de santé
qui soit complet
et qui soit rapide.
- Quentin Calmet:
Une dernière question
sur ce texte.
On voit d'autres mesures,
comme l'encadrement
de l'intérim médical,
la suppression
du certificat médical
pour être remplacé
par un certificat
d'honneur sur l'absence
en cas d'enfant malade...
Il y a des choses
intéressantes
dans cette proposition de loi?
- Bernard Jomier:
La question des certificats
médicaux, on a voté cet article.
Ca va permettre
de gagner un peu
de temps.
Toutes ces mesures
de simplification
sont bonnes à prendre.
Nous les votons, d'ailleurs.
Après, il y a tout un ensemble
de mesures
qui est inutile.
- Kathia Gilder:
On parle du projet
de loi de financement
du budget
de la Sécurité sociale
qui est à l'ordre
du jour à l'Assemblée nationale.
Mais le débat a tourné court.
Elisabeth Borne a déclenché
un nouveau 49.3
sur la première
partie de ce budget.
Si le gouvernement
n'avait pas utilisé
le 49.3, il aurait pu
faire autrement?
- Bernard Jomier:
Si le budget
de la Sécurité sociale
n'a pas été adopté
en commission,
c'est peut-être
qu'il est très mauvais.
Quand vous regardez
la gestion
de la Sécurité sociale
par le gouvernement,
le budget qu'il nous présente
est déficitaire
et notamment
sur les cinq années à venir.
La première option politique
qu'on doit prendre
sur le budget
de la Sécurité sociale,
c'est de le ramener à l'équilibre.
Il était quasiment
à l'équilibre
en 2017 et 2018,
quand Emmanuel Macron
a été élu chef de l'Etat.
- Kathia Gilder:
Le gouvernement
se targue pourtant de faire
des mesures d'économies.
-
Bernard Jomier:
Ce n'est pas ce que disent
les chiffres.
8 milliards de déficit
sur l'Assurance maladie
en 2024 et 11 milliards
l'année suivante.
Le gouvernement laisse
la Sécurité sociale
en déficit, et ça s'explique
très simplement.
Le gouvernement
ne donne pas de perspectives
positives,
alors que la Sécurité sociale,
c'est un dispositif
très important.
Si on le laisse
en déficit, on envoie
le message qu'il faut
réduire les coûts.
- Kathia Gilder:
On va changer de sujet.
Actualité internationale.
Un débat a eu lieu
à l'Assemblée nationale
et au Sénat sur la situation
au Proche-Orient.
Elisabeth Borne
a redit le soutien
de la France à Israël,
en appelant toutefois
à une trêve à Gaza.
Il n'y avait pas foule
mais beaucoup
de tension en séance.
- Dans un hémicycle à moitié vide,
Elisabeth Borne peine
à se faire entendre.
- En prononçant ces mots...
- Les députés s'invectivent.
- S'il vous plaît,
mes chers collègues.
- La veille, le tweet
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon concernant
la présence de Yaël
Braun-Pivet en Israël
a encore accentué les tensions.
- Je vous apporte
mon soutien suite
aux attaques
intolérables
dont vous avez fait l'objet
ces derniers jours.
- J'affirme ici mon soutien
à la présidente
de notre Assemblée
après l'attaque abjecte
dont elle a été la cible hier.
- La Première ministre
fustige une fois
encore les déclarations
des Insoumis
sur cette guerre
entre Israël
et le Hamas.
- Nous ne devons faire preuve
d'aucune ambiguïté
sur cette guerre.
Ceux qui justifient
le terrorisme commettent
une faute morale,
politique et stratégique.
- Elisabeth Borne réclame
une trêve humanitaire
et réaffirme
la position historique
de la France.
- La France, autrefois...
- Un peu de silence!
- La France est devenue
un pays aligné
sur les Etats-Unis et Israël.
- Au Sénat,
le lendemain, le climat
est plus apaisé.
La Première ministre confirme
le déblocage d'une aide
humanitaire
supplémentaire
pour les Palestiniens.
- Pas un euro ne doit aller
à une organisation
de type terroriste comme le Hamas.
- Nous ne pouvons accepter
que l'Etat d'Israël,
que le gouvernement
de Benyamin Netanyahou,
passe du droit
à se défendre à un droit
à se venger.
- C'est la position de la France.
- Kathia Gilder:
Petite question
sur la position
de la France, qui tente
de maintenir un équilibre
entre soutien
sans faille à Israël
mais aussi appel
à une trêve humanitaire.
Cette position française
est-elle claire
et cohérente?
- Bernard Jomier:
Oui, dans la dimension d'abord
d'un commentaire
sans ambiguïté
sur l'attaque du 7 octobre.
L'attaque du 7 octobre,
c'est une attaque barbare
d'un groupe terroriste.
S'il y a une telle
différence
entre l'hémicycle
du Sénat,
tous les groupes
politiques ont condamné
le Hamas.
Ca, c'est la photo.
Quand survient un événement
comme celui-là,
vous prenez position
sur cette photo.
Le problème,
c'est que les Insoumis
ont voulu contextualiser,
c'est-à-dire regarder
le film, ce qui se passe
depuis plusieurs décennies.
- Kathia Gilder: C'est une erreur?
- Bernard Jomier:
C'est une infamie!
Quand vous faites
de la politique,
vous commencez
par affirmer des valeurs,
des valeurs d'humanité.
Si vous ne partagez pas
ces valeurs d'humanité,
vous ne pouvez pas partager
d'autres combats politiques.
La France, en partant
de cette condamnation,
sans faiblir
de ce qui s'est passé
le 7 octobre, puis en rappelant...
Je me félicite
de la diplomatie française.
La France soutient
une solution
à deux Etats.
A gauche,
il y a cette fracture
que tout le monde voit,
mais à droite,
Les Républicains,
qui sont un mouvement
qui avait vocation
à gouverner le pays,
qui a défendu
cette solution
à deux Etats,
j'entends maintenant
le président
des Républicains dériver
sur une ligne qui est une lecture
occidentaliste
du conflit.
- Quentin Calmet:
De quoi parlez-vous?
- Bernard Jomier:
J'ai entendu le président
des Républicains,
Eric Ciotti,
ne plus reprendre
cette solution
à deux Etats
et se ranger
dans cette vision
de guerre de religions,
de vision de l'Occident
contre le reste
du monde.
Il y cette vision
idéologique
sur ce conflit.
C'est traditionnel de la France.
C'est une fracture
profonde à droite.
- Quentin Calmet:
Cette semaine,
le chef de l'Etat
s'est déplacé
dans plusieurs pays
du Proche-Orient.
Après Israël,
la Jordanie et l'Egypte.
- Bernard Jomier:
Je n'ai pas compris
la position d'Emmanuel Macron.
Il veut à tout prix
faire croire
que la France
a une influence
dans la région, au prix d'une
proposition iconoclaste.
Cela porte le clivage
que je dénonce.
Vous avez vu la réponse
des pays arabes.
- Quentin Calmet:
Cette proposition
était mal préparée?
- Bernard Jomier:
Elle n'a pas de sens.
Ce n'est pas la position
politique
de ce qui se passe en Israël.
Il y a un peuple
palestinien, il existe.
Ses droits
ont été bafoués
depuis trop longtemps.
L'absence de solution
politique crée
un chaos.
Vous avez une puissance
régionale, l'Iran,
qui mêle à ce conflit local
une dimension religieuse,
une dimension islamiste.
Là, vous avez un amalgame
qui se constitue.
Vous avez, en France,
des lectures politiques
qui ont l'air satisfaites
de cet amalgame,
qui le portent,
alors qu'il est dangereux.
C'est pour cela qu'il faut
en revenir
à la position équilibrée
et traditionnelle
de la France.
- Kathia Gilder:
Le problème est complexe
et global.
Ne pensez-vous pas
que la France
et ses gouvernements
successifs
ont un peu abandonné
le Proche-Orient
à son sort?
- Bernard Jomier:
En tout cas, la communauté
internationale,
le conseil de sécurité
de l'ONU
se sont désintéressés
de la situation au Proche-Orient.
On a donné l'impression
de ne pas condamner suffisamment
la dérive du gouvernement
israélien.
Rappelez-vous quand un dirigeant
a été assassiné
par un jeune extrémiste.
Nous avons laissé faire.
Nous n'avons pas parlé
suffisamment fort.
La voix de la France s'est
éteinte tranquillement.
Peut-être
parce qu'il y avait d'autres
priorités.
- Quentin Calmet:
On en vient au dernier point
dans ce projet de loi immigration.
Il arrive à l'ordre
du jour du Sénat.
Il a été plusieurs fois repoussé.
Les tensions
sont fortes
autour de ce texte.
Le gouvernement
espère un texte
pour la fin de l'année.
- Les Républicains
sont d'accord
avec nous pour dire
qu'on peut rectifier
tout ça par voie circulaire.
Le seul point,
c'est que dans un article
de la loi, l'article 3,
on puisse dire
qu'on va changer la circulaire.
A l'Assemblée,
il y a des gens
qui vous disent
que s'il n'y a pas ça,
ils ne votent pas.
Le problème,
c'est de savoir si on veut
que ce texte soit voté ou pas.
- Quentin Calmet:
L'article 3,
c'est sur la régularisation
des sans-papiers
dans les métiers en tension.
Que pensez-vous de ce texte?
- Bernard Jomier:
Ca doit être la 28e
ou 29e loi en 30
ans sur le sujet
de l'immigration.
En une trentaine d'années,
il y a eu autant
de lois.
Il y a un point
auquel je souscris
tout à fait,
c'est qu'on n'a pas vraiment
besoin d'une loi sur ce sujet.
Cette volonté
de légiférer sans cesse
est une volonté
de posture politique.
Quand vous lisez
la loi, ne serait-ce
que les titres
de chaque article,
c'est une loi de peur.
C'est une loi de repli sur soi.
- Kathia Gilder:
On peut déjà régulariser
par d'autres voies.
- Bernard Jomier:
Une partie du monde politique,
à droite
et à l'extrême droite,
ainsi qu'une partie
de la majorité présidentielle,
a des réactions
de rejet vis-à-vis
des étrangers
qui sont présents
sur notre sol
et qui ne posent
aucun problème.
Les mêmes qui vont le soir
au restaurant
et sont contents
du repas qu'ils font
ne vont pas ouvrir
la porte de la cuisine.
Ils verraient
derrière des étrangers
qui font la cuisine,
qui mènent
une vie paisible,
qui se lèvent tôt
le matin et travaillent
tard le soir.
Ils ne veulent qu'une chose,
qu'on reconnaisse
ce qu'ils font pour notre pays.
Les mêmes prennent
des postures
sur cet article 3,
en disant
qu'on ne peut pas régulariser.
C'est faux.
- Quentin Calmet:
Y a-t-il une impasse politique
pour le gouvernement?
L'aile gauche
de la majorité tient
à cet article 3.
Est-ce que c'est une impasse
politique
pour Gérald Darmanin?
- Bernard Jomier:
Le gouvernement s'est mis
tout seul dans cette impasse.
Il n'y avait aucune nécessité
de légiférer
sur cette question.
Si vous regardez
l'ensemble du texte,
il ne porte
que des points
qui sont des points
de rejet d'étrangers.
Quand vous êtes étranger
en France...
- Kathia Gilder:
A fortiori, s'il n'y
a plus cet article
3 dans le texte?
- Bernard Jomier: Oui.
Il y a d'autres
articles qui portent
sur les étrangers
malades, par exemple.
Ce qui est marquant,
c'est qu'on ne veut
plus des étrangers
malades
dans notre pays.
Par contre, on veut
prendre les médecins
des pays du sud.
On est un pays qui se replie.
C'est un texte
de peur, de repli
et de rejet.
Ce n'est pas à la hauteur
de notre pays.
Notre pays change,
le monde change.
Vouloir penser qu'on va revenir...
C'est ce
qu'il y a derrière tout ça.
On parle aussi
de terrorisme islamiste,
au fond.
Certains collègues
de droite posent
des amendements.
On voit le mélange des thèmes.
Notre pays a peur, il se replie.
Il pense qu'il va revenir
aux années 50.
- Quentin Calmet:
Retirer un titre
de séjour
à une personne
qui ne respecte pas
les valeurs
de la République...
C'est ce qui est à l'article
10 du texte.
Ca, c'est du bon sens, non?
Le respect des valeurs
de la République,
c'est ce qu'on peut attendre.
- Bernard Jomier:
Il y a quelques dispositions
dans ce texte
qui sont acceptables.
Mais la philosophie
du texte est détestable.
Vous parlez de respecter
les valeurs
de la République.
Certains amendements
proposent de retirer
les titres de séjour
à quelqu'un
qui a commis une faute mineure.
On est bien
dans une lecture politique
qui est une lecture de peur.
C'est destiné à empêcher
l'extrême droite
de se développer, peut-être.
Mais toujours est-il
que nous combattons fermement
cette ligne.
Elle n'est pas à la hauteur
de ce qu'est
la France.
- Kathia Gilder:
Ce sera compliqué
pour le gouvernement.
Le débat n'a pas encore commencé.
Si les choses
sont mal engagées
pour le gouvernement,
peut-il recourir
à un nouveau 49.3?
Celui-là sera précieux.
On est plus dans le débat
budgétaire.
- Bernard Jomier:
Utiliser la procédure
du 49.3, c'est-à-dire
empêcher le Parlement
de délibérer sur une question
aussi importante,
ce n'est pas pour dire
que le budget
n'est pas important,
mais sur une question sociétale,
ce serait un aveu d'échec
pour le gouvernement.
Il n'est pas en situation
de faire comprendre
et de faire accepter
sa ligne politique
à sa propre majorité.
La majorité
présidentielle elle-même
est divisée sur ce texte.
Le gouvernement
se sera mis lui-même
dans l'échec.
- Quentin Calmet:
La transformation d'une aide
médicale d'Etat en aide
médicale d'urgence,
comme la droite
va sûrement le voter,
qu'en pensez-vous?
- Bernard Jomier:
Les Républicains
sont en perte
de valeur totale,
pour une partie d'entre eux.
C'est un dispositif
de santé publique.
Refuser de soigner
les gens,
c'est le reniement
de ce qu'a été
la position
des Républicains
pendant des décennies.
- Kathia Gilder:
Merci d'avoir été
avec nous.
- Quentin Calmet:
A la semaine prochaine.
SOUS-TITRAGE LIVE: RED BEE MEDIA